the summer it's City race ends skiers
right through the center of town a slope
is built there so local residents and
tourists can celebrate the start of the
winter season
mom and I so it's great that the season
starting again we live from scheme and
it shows everyone here is involved heart
and soul in an event like this nice to
look forward for the snow and a good
vintage season in summer it's this is
really the beginning of a good season I
think I all its now to really start we
need just one more meter of snow and it
will be perfect it snowed heavily again
in the night so when the slopes around
summer it's open for the first day of
the season winter sports fans found the
best possible skiing conditions hi this
is our home and it's the best place for
skiing yeah fantastic especially with
this weather in these slope conditions
overwhelming give I do lunch you just
glide over the hills it's almost like
flying submitting we fleeing Andre upon
chera grew up in this region and used to
be a professional skier the artists
money which is my big passion I used to
spend 360 days a year in ski boots so
it's in my heart / 10 that's black adam
haston on
now Andrea works as a ski instructor
teaching beginners how to zip across the
snow dear folks the thrill of success
the first time you manage to go down the
slope people here are so good they
probably can't imagine it a short break
at the bar in the ski hut that too is a
new experience for you li are cooking up
missing conditioner I can understand why
so many people go in for a frisky it's
not bad at all but only with the ski
instructors seeing and being seen is but
what summer its is all about you mean it
might be my outfit is not ideal next
time I come back to sac Moritz I'll wear
things that are more chic and I'll come
with sunglasses too that looks cooler
nice and my tummy tummy doesn't happen a
visitor from be some cool ass the right
equipment is crucial the big brands of
unveiled their new products for the
season in summer its equipment is
increasingly specialized one trend this
winter is all mountain skis and repin
scherer can use them for cross country
tours or unprepared slopes to carve that
means to ski in fast curves they put
them these are the perfect skis in the
morning after it snows i can go
cross-country skiing and deep snow and
then spend the rest of the day alpine
skiing help the piece design baby and
dog give you a model that's a bit softer
on the perfect size and its design is
attractive to with women the design
always has to be right
beginner you leah is trying out some
shorter skis they make it easier to turn
in the snow
yeah although I'm so positively
surprised how productive I thought I'd
be a lot more awkward and when you fly
down the slopes it's such a feeling of
freedom get food from fly high orbit
I've dish and the backdrop in and around
summer it's is breathtaking summer it's
is in the Engadine Valley in the Swiss
Alps it's famous as a luxury ski resort
other insult my latest episode which has
something very important when the Sun
shines the sky is a very special blue
but this isn't a tall tale when the Sun
shines the sky here is just different DJ
antoine is one of switzerland's best
known musicians internationally on the
season opening weekend he provided the
music at the après-ski at 15 degrees
below zero Celsius I love to ski the
problem is that I do so much traveling
that lately I've let it slip of it but
this January for the first time in three
or four years I'm going to ski in some
of its again so summer its is
celebrating the start of the ski season
and with his concert DJ antoine has
already provided one of the seasons high
points
Oh